I wanted to make something special for my husband today,
so I decided to make him a pumpkin cheesecake.
After baking a sugar pie pumpkin and scooping out the delicious splash,
I got started on my filling.
It's impossible to find a real cheesecake with quality ingredients,
minimally sweet, and that tastes good, too.
But here we are. Pasteurized cream cheese,
probiotic sour cream, pumpkin,
coconut sugar, lots of pumpkin pie spice,
eggs for my chickens, vanilla and unrefined sea salt.
Next, I whipped up the keto crust
using crispy walnuts and almonds I had soaked and dehydrated
to remove phytic acid and neutralize enzyme inhibitors.
Combined with a half a cup of dates,
I pressed this into a springform pan
and then poured my filling up to the top.
This baked for 40 minutes at 300 degrees Fahrenheit.
When it was cool, I placed it in the fridge,
and many hours later when it was cold,
I got to making my fresh caramel drizzle.
I then whipped up some raw cinnamon whipped cream,
which only took about one minute,
and then I finished the cheesecake.
The springform pan attached perfectly.
I flipped the cheesecake onto a cake stand
and then drizzled caramel over top,
followed by a bunch of fresh whip.
The moment of truth came when I cut into this thick cheesecake.
All I could hope for was the cheesecake flavor with a crunchy,
perfect crust. It was so insane.
Mouth watering, really.
My husband told me it Was the best dessert I had ever made.